a single postage stamp costs 44 cents
how much would a roll of 1,000 stamps
cost and there's really a couple of ways
to do it and I'll do it both ways just
to show you they both work one is a kind
of a faster way but I want to make sure
you understand why it works and then
we'll verify that it actually gives us
the right answer using maybe the more
traditional way of multiplying decimals
so we're starting at 44 cents I'll just
write a 0.44 well that's one stamp so
this is one stamp I'll write it like
this one stamp how much would ten stamps
cost well if one stamp is forty four
cents then ten stamps we could move the
decimal to the right one place and so it
would be and now this leading zero is
not that useful so it would now be four
point four dollars or if you want to
make it clear would be four dollars and
40 cents now what happens if you want to
have a hundred stamps a hundred stamps
well the same idea is going to happen
we're now taking ten times more so we're
going to move to the decimal to the
right ones so 100 stamps are going to
cost are going to cost forty four
dollars and this should make sense for
you if one stamp is forty four forty
four hundredths of a dollar then 100
stamps are going to be forty four
hundredths of a hundred dollars or forty
four dollars or you could view it as
we've just moved the decimal over one
place so if we want a thousand stamps if
we want a thousand stamps we'd move the
decimal to the right one more time
moving the decimal to the right is
equivalent to multiplying by ten so then
it would be four hundred and forty
dollars now we could put add another
trailing zero just to make clear that
there's no sense over here so if you
wanted to do it really click quickly you
could have started with forty four cents
and you say look I'm not multiplying by
ten I'm not multiplying by a hundred I'm
multiplying by a thousands you're going
to have to put another trailing zero
over here and you would move the decimal
from over here to over here you've
essentially you've essentially
multiplied this times ten times ten
times ten which is a thousand so then
this would become four hundred and forty
dollars four hundred and forty dollars
so let's verify that this works exactly
the same if we
multiplied the traditional way the way
we multiply decimals so if you have 1000
1000 times 44 cents times 44 cents so
you start over here 4 times 0 is 0 4
times 0 is 0 4 times 0 is 0 4 times 1 is
4 or you could just say hey this was 4
times a thousand then we're going to go
one place over so we're going to add a 0
and we ate once again we're gonna have 4
times 0 is 0 4 times 0 is 0 4 times 0 is
0 4 times 1 is 4 or we just did 4 times
a thousand so that is 4000 if you don't
include this 0 that we added here ahead
of time because we're going one place to
the left and then we have nothing left I
haven't at all thought about the
decimals right now so far I really
distributed it as a thousand times 44
I've been ignoring the decimal so for
1000 times 44 we would get zero plus
zero zero zero plus zero zero zero plus
zero zero four plus 0 is 4 4 4 plus
nothing is four and if you ignore the
decimal that makes a lot of sense
because a thousand times four is four
thousand and a thousand times 40 would
be 40,000 so you would get 44,000 but
this of course is not a 44 this is a
forty four hundredths we have between
the two numbers two numbers behind the
decimal point so we need to have two
numbers behind or to the right of the
decimal point in our answer so one two
right over there so once again we get
four hundred and forty dollars for the
thousand stamps